chaos overtakes the streets and news
spreads like wildfire
sea levels have suddenly risen 500
meters and giant waves are headed your
way
where could you hide to survive this
catastrophe
would your city be destroyed
and
what would it take to trigger a disaster
of such epic proportions
this is what if and here's what would
happen if sea levels suddenly rose 500
meters
there's no shortage of data flooding the
internet regarding rising sea levels
global warming has been progressively
melting our ice sheets and glaciers
over the past 100 years
sea levels have increased by about 24
centimeters
but for all of the oceans to rise 500
meters
you'd need a lot more ice than our
planet has to offer
which leads to another big question
just how much ice would it take to flood
earth
let's be clear earth does have a lot of
ice but even if all of it suddenly
melted overnight
it would only cause a rise of about 70
meters
now this would send all coastal cities
underwater
forcing over 3 billion people to leave
their homes and head for higher ground
but that would be just a soggy walk in
the park compared to the disastrous
aftermath if our planet had seven times
more ice and
all of it suddenly melted
now you'd be looking at a towering half
kilometer rise in sea
levels and devastating
is anything but an understatement
would it be enough to submerge all of
the land on earth
well luckily no the average elevation of
land above sea level is about
840 meters so there would still be some
ground left for you to move to
i mean that is unless you wanted to move
to australia
that continent would now be almost 200
meters underwater
europe could face a similar fate with
many of its countries sitting way below
the 500 meter mark
places like denmark and the netherlands
would be completely submerged while
spain and france might keep their
highest peaks above the water
the united states and canada wouldn't be
ideal places for survival either
most of north america would now be the
ocean floor
so where could you find safety among the
chaos
well try africa
this continent usually sits at about 600
meters above sea level
so some big patches of it would stand a
chance to remain dry
if you want an even better chance at
survival you'd go to chile or
afghanistan
these countries have some of the highest
elevations on the planet so they'd
likely suffer the least
but your absolute best bet at a better
post-apocalyptic life
well look to china
yeah not only does china have higher
elevations
it would also become the largest and
most powerful nation on earth
but you might be short on time to get
there
billions of people would perish as
coastal floods swallow entire cities
and countries
even if the few survivors somehow
managed to reach higher ground
the disaster wouldn't end there
most farmland across the globe would be
destroyed
it would either be submerged or
contaminated by salt water making it
impossible to grow food
the remaining land would belong to
mountain peaks where the soil would
likely be infertile
and there wouldn't be too many trees for
you to build a house or start a fire
and you would need four walls to protect
you from bad weather
since it would all be out of whack
that's because this newly diluted ocean
water would cause some ocean currents to
stop
by just taking the gulf stream out of
the global climate equation
temperatures would plummet and maybe
even trigger a mini ice age
you'd barely find any food to eat
almost all the land animals would drown
and fish
well marine life wouldn't be so lucky
either
they're used to living in a higher salt
concentration so when the glaciers melt
and dilute the salt water with fresh
water
all the fish would bloat and die
it's all scary stuff but
what about humans
well our own water reservoirs would
mostly be wiped out
that's because the ocean water would
infiltrate groundwater reserves and
pollute nearby fresh water
turning drinking water undrinkable
yeah
put on your thinking cap because you'd
have to find some clever ways to recycle
water to drink
and with that
the big blue sphere we call home
would truly become almost exclusively
blue and
barely our home at all
yeah so maybe you shouldn't play with
ice
or better yet you could make sure none
of this ever happens
by trying to re-freeze the arctic
[Music]
yeah but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]